play the list transcription from Aida
when hands cast opus is in the
sanatorium as I said the gramophone
arrives and he listens to lots of
different sorts of music and one of the
pieces of music he listens to a lot is
Aida and I just read you a little bit
from though from the novel one small
group of records contained the closing
scenes of a grandiose opera overflowing
with melodic genius written by one of
hair set in greenies compatriots an old
southern master of musical drama who had
composed it in the second half of the
previous century on commission from an
oriental prince as part of solemn
ceremonies at the dedication of a work
of technology which would bring nations
closer together hands cast off was more
or less familiar with the plot new the
rough outline of the tragic fate of
raddimus an heiress and Aida who sang to
him from the cabinet an incomparable
tenor a stately met so with that
splendid break in the middle of her
register and a silvery support soprano
it was all in Italian but he understood
more or less what they sang not every
word but enough here and there
give him his knowledge of the plot and
his sympathy for its situations a
personal empathy that had increased each
time he played the four or five records
until it now had become a genuine
infatuation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]